I got a call from a guy named Howard o
Sackler who later wrote the great white
hope he won the Pulitzer Prize at that
time Sackler who knew Stan Lee from the
Bronx had seen me in an off-broadway
play called he who gets slapped which I
co-produced for $100 way off Broadway
and I get a call from Sackler saying I
saw you and playing the lead and he'll
get slapped and I think you're perfect
for the part of Sydney in this movie
that I've written a movie which by the
way Stan Lee later tried to have the
negative burned little did he know how
much we all hated it no we didn't in any
case I go to this address I was from
Brooklyn and he was from the Bronx it's
a long story but there's a payoff I
guess I go there and I ring the doorbell
and I go upstairs I walked up three or
four flights and the door opens and this
guy with the dark eyes a very bare bill
room with the cameras not not movie
cameras just cameras right I'm still
cameras he was working for Look magazine
and he said to me and I'm Stanley
Kubrick and I said I'm Owen Mazursky
which is my real name is Irwin and I was
smart I changed this ball I don't know
why he changed it to Paul but that's
another story
in any case he said I want you to read
for me would you read for me I said yeah
so I read I have no idea what I'm
reading it took about 40 minutes was a
very short like 60 page thing he said
okay you got the part we leave Monday
for California I said but I'm graduating
from college I can't I can't do that he
said you can do it go to the Dean and
tell him you're in a big Hollywood movie
and ask ask for four weeks off so I go
to the Dean the next day and lo and
behold he fell for it
Stanley was just a remarkable person and
I grew to like him two years later we
looped the movie and when I saw it I
figured Oscar I go crazy I rape a girl I
sing the song from tempest 4005
other lives of his bones the coral made
I did all that
alright twenty thousand bucks he needed
another five thousand dollars he decided
to go down the hill we were up in a Boy
Scout camp but that's where we shot the
movie in the San Gabriel Mountains and
he said I'm gonna go I'm driving down to
see my uncle Martin preveli reveller was
a they had a drug store right and he had
a thing you know we've an adding machine
and he would say you know how many ask
for and I have to sell they give you
$5,000 more well how the hell am I gonna
get my money back Stanley said you're
gonna give it to me you're gonna give it
to me and when we drove down the hill
frankzilla Vera and I were in the back
of the car this is true everything I
tell you is true who was in front with
him Virginia no just just him and he got
so determined I'm gonna get it I'm gonna
get the five
I'll get the five thousand that he spat
on the windshield of the car I had kind
of determination in a young man and I
realized that if I want to get anywhere
in Hollywood I'm gonna spit my way
through it